ok, j'ai juste besoin de regarder
dessus, le petit trois est
ici, ok, où est-il, où est-il, euh, à
ma droite, à côté du ruisseau,
il court en premier, où est-
il, à droite, au centre, à gauche, ouais, vous l'avez,
c'est qu'il cherche  chez nous c'est un loup ouais
c'est un loup blanc
wow
le chasseur est
pourchassé il coule vers
moi toujours en courant si
vite
je vais arrêter d'enregistrer maintenant d'
accord
peut-être construire la roue euh attends euh ok
un un un D
ouais je
fais exactement la même chose
qu'hier  il nous regarde et puis il
court
Fus il va retomber tu as failli tomber
peut-être que c'est le même,
essayons de nous en rapprocher oh on se
rapproche oh c'est un coup de NIC
hier oh oh cool
ni
oh il y a tellement d'
eau
comme ça
ouais
oh l'oiseau a tiré
ouais ouais
Z de front jusqu'à ce qu'ils ralentissent
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est
parti maintenant et
maintenant
wow je pensais que c'était
[Applaudissements] de
l'eau,
ils ralentiront
finalement en revenant après l'
arrêt des Pates  H il fait des
conneries il veut chier
c'est
bon
ok prends une
photo Le loup fait des conneries quand le loup
fait des
conneries jolie